[Music]
Here Comes the Bride Selena Gomez stuns
in a classic wedding gown I love it
that's the actress rocking a strapless
dress with a full tulle skirt matching
white gloves and a lace veil the look
topped off with a bold red lip and white
pearl drop earrings truly a bridal
Vision oh my goodness as for why Selena
is looking like she's ready to say I do
well it's all for her Hulu series only
murders in the building is this really
happened again well you know who are we
without a homicide Selena is a New York
filming scenes with her co-stars Martin
Short and Steve Martin for season three
of the show
Amiga I should say we got even more
shots of the bridal Bonanza over on
Instagram cell kept the Glam look casual
with a pair of white chunky boots I'm
just so confident and comfortable and I
feel free more than I've ever felt in my
whole life as for Martin and Steve they
both look dapper and tailored black
Texas arm in arm with the bride and uh
let's just call out the obvious here all
this feels like a total throwback to the
actor's classic 90s rom-com Father of
the Bride I'll bring the wrong color
tread I seem to be wearing a blocked I
follow
it is a black taxado I don't think so
babe now
why Selena's character Mabel is wearing
a wedding gown well that is still TBD
but
there's lots in store for season three
including star-studded guests
we do certainly have great guest stars I
would like to think people are lining up
on the lineup Andrea Martin and Paul
Rudd the gang is back hello yay could
this honestly get any better oh wait
oh well I do think it could get a little
bit better Paul actually had a cameo in
the season two finale
good luck tonight
thanks
good luck as a curse in the theater
the actor is expected to have a bigger
role in the new season but the surprise
of all surprises came in the form of the
one and only Meryl Streep
no please thank you thank you ma'am
uh just the tea that I had asked for a
half an hour ago I'm okay thank you for
your sweet
to be in that room Selena is great and
I've worked with Selena and she's a
really good friend of mine uh adore her
Martin Short and Steve Martin are Mount
Rushmore and then you pan over and it's
Meryl Streep so yeah a bit of a
Powerhouse oh my God
I'm sorry it's me isn't it do you get
lost in the sauce when all of that is in
the room there's just that oh I don't I
don't want to get in the way of anything
and I also just really acknowledge how
great they are I have many I can't
believe I'm in this room right now
moments
[Music]
thank you